this is a production of cornell
university
yeah welcome back everyone this is the
16th episode of the cornell turf show
this year our guest today is john
sorakin from the university of tennessee
a little rocky top action for you guys
today
we're gonna talk uh sports fields uh
athlete safety there's some interesting
stuff john's doing now with uh infield
depth uh impact attenuation i saw some
interesting stuff there john i'm sure
frank is is uh on the scent of that and
we'll chat about that uh quick note for
our podcast listeners if you guys listen
regularly through the podcasts uh we'd
love some uh feedback from you guys
leave a review uh leave a
rating you can call us idiots you can
call us great uh we just want some
feedback that's exactly right this sucks
i got better things to do that's right
so uh frank i'll turn it over to you i
think you're live from
a very famous golf course down there on
long island that's right live from the
beth page state park i got to go around
from six o'clock this morning just got
to go around the entire black course but
we're talking sports fields today carl
and
that's something that many sports field
managers are spending a fair amount of
time uh doing uh throughout the year and
and here's this guy trying to get the
thing painted before the rain starts
coming down right because you can see it
you know right behind his back there so
obviously uh you know painting lines and
dealing with the weather you can see
come some construction in the background
equipment that you've got to move uh
sports field managers generally have to
be uh on their toes all the time uh
moving things around and dealing with
athletes but they always need a good
companion and here's a little guy i do
not you know now you got sports field
guys bringing their dogs uh to these
setup operations and carl we wouldn't
have it any other way i know you're a
good dog owner but i think you got a
really cool stat for us having to do
with footwear today
yeah and it's it's more i think a tip of
the day frank and
and we've talked about this with andy
mcnitt in the past but the influence on
footwear
for athletes and how that relates to
injury risk and
um it it when you especially when you
have a high traction surface we're going
to talk about synthetic fields today
when we've done some measuring of our
surfaces here at cornell the synthetic
field always rates very highly in our
traction measuring devices if you put a
high traction field with a high traction
shoe
the athlete loves that because they can
really break and turn
very well but the problem is that stress
is
absorbed by all the ligaments and in the
lower body injuries and and we see
higher rates of those sorts of
uh catastrophic injuries uh higher on
synthetic surfaces so
for your coaches make sure they have
access to something like this database
this is a free database penn state has
they rank a bunch of shoes every
different year
you'll see the models there they have a
little traction score so just be aware
that if you're doing some safety
monitoring on your fields and you have
high traction values
make sure that your coaches know their
athletes are wearing shoes that are
appropriate for that surface
and and john you know you've played
around with this a little bit right i
mean i think we've talked about this
andy doesn't use that big monster that
the university of virginia developed to
do this does he no he uses the pen foot
and uh and you know then bridget
university of virginia has
on biocore they have what's called the
beast right and we have what we have we
have two devices the flex and
peak yeah so so so um
but for data to pick shoes this isn't
terrible
no it's it's a good start i mean andy's
not doesn't really simulate the pen foot
doesn't simulate an actual foot strike
in the
impacts but it can tell you differences
between
you know traction with the different
shoes they put on in terms of one that's
giving you a higher load than another on
the on the movement that they're doing
all right good all right so listen let
me get through the weather a little bit
then we're gonna really get into the
teeth of
a good sports turf conversation and as
we've been saying pretty much for the 16
episodes uh we are well into our roller
coaster we have another uh bunch of
roller coaster weather going on here you
can see it up and down
up and down and then we go to may and
we're starting to head up a little bit
and i can tell you down here uh it looks
like it's going to get windy and cold in
the metropolitan new york area as you
get a little bit further north it's
actually going to be quite a bit warmer
and clearer than normal last week was a
pretty cool week you can see the
majority of the northeast was below
normal uh and of course that and
therefore that meant not a big
accumulation of degree days so i
continue to see
the lack of advancement
of the growing season which you know in
my mind if you're playing sports
on grass that's not actively growing
because you're not getting good growing
conditions
the likelihood of that turf wearing out
quicker and i think also i would argue
as we get to it
a better use for synthetic turf when the
grass isn't growing to get those
athletes on something uh that won't do
as much that they won't damage as much
now the outlook as i said looks warmer
the further you get away from the coast
and so you're likely to accumulate a
significant amount of degree days uh
away from the coast and certainly to the
southern region so we are expecting a
little bit of a warm-up in in
inland but along the coast it'll still
be on the chilly side now um you know
when we're before we get into soil
moisture we had evan machete on a couple
of shows ago and and we wouldn't have a
sports turf conversation if we weren't
talking about infield skin and some guy
on twitter was bragging about his great
cleat-in cleat out work he says he's
finally got the dirt uh at the right
moisture so you know one of the things
that's fascinating about sports turf is
that it's not just grass right you've
got uh you got these infields
sand systems and of course we're going
to talk about uh synthetic turf so the
rainfall it's been on the dry side uh
throughout much of the northeast uh
until you get up into the far reaches of
northern new england so overall we're
starting to see evapotranspiration
compensate for light rainfall you know
we'll lose between a half and three
quarters of an inch uh
evapotranspiration so you're starting to
see
deficits over a week-long period when we
don't get rainfall and it looks like we
might be around neutral to a little bit
of a slight deficit but overall looks
like we're going to be drying out
in the near term which i think bodes
well in some cases
because we have had plenty of moisture
up to this point to keep the grass
actively growing now soils are still
remarkably cool and again when you think
about grass growing and traffic
tolerance
cool soils are not really perfect for
for good top growth right so one of the
things that happens is i find myself you
know wanting to recommend
more sports turf managers have synthetic
surfaces available now uh here at
cornell uh where we tape two dollar
bills to the back of our pads for
reasons that i don't entirely understand
but we are really good at missing
tackles uh on a regular basis uh so
today
um uh you know we i just bring up some
of the highlighted
things that have come to mind around
synthetic turf and i think it came to a
head
uh back in the super bowl when odell
beckham is cutting across the middle
he's starting to have the game of his
career real breakout game
i think it was early in the first
quarter he's cutting across the field
nobody's near him you could tell he
planted his foot uh in a in a really
stiff way and the next thing you know uh
the knee buckle now this was on the
heels of our cornell alum and foreign
former cleveland browns center i don't
know where he's wound up right now the
current nflpa president j.c tretter uh
coming out uh and saying back in 2020 we
gotta convert these fields from
synthetic turf to natural grass
makes a very pointed comment uh about
things that john studies on a pretty
regular basis
high levels of power and rotation on the
playing surface
um the grass gives and it releases the
cleat before it reaches a harmful load
you can tell this guy's a cornell grad
right john so
along come the best management practices
out of the the mid-atlantic region
for uh guys for environmental stuff but
thankfully in there
um there's a section on synthetic turf
it has some environmental impact as well
but there are some really key things
about maintenance uh performing it in
accordance with um the uh warranty uh
best management practices right and so
the thing that comes up when you start
looking at best management practices and
shown very clearly you know you see astm
standards you see guidelines right you
you there's a warranties right there are
very clear things you're taking field
temperature preferably with an infrared
thermometer right so there's lots of
different
ways of looking at synthetic turf that
we generally
unfortunately don't always follow with
natural grass systems i i find that sort
of interesting in and among itself and
so when we start to bring up standards
right the astm group has come up with
the f-155 1551
standard that was updated in 2018
that will give you guidance on how these
things uh these surfaces should be
maintained and of course john has the
center for athletic field safety i had
the pleasure of having a lovely
conversation with john on my other
podcast
for turf net
about this
particular subject as well as footwear
john is intimately involved with the
nfl and he just published an article not
long ago on is testing your synthetic
field importance this looks like a depth
gauge to me maybe a traction gauge john
is it a depth gauge or a traction gauge
it's an infill depth gauge yeah okay it
is an infield depth gauge and i think
this is probably the thing that's uh
been changed a lot is that now that we
have this infill
depth data um there are really important
things to measure but in that
article that i've seen you write and
write other articles you cite this
particular paper that was published
familiar because it's all your brethren
calgary it's all your alberta natives
what i thought was fascinating within
your hometown what i thought was
fascinating here john this is a good
launching point because i got a couple
of questions but you know this is a
study that was done purposefully setting
up
different surface characteristics um
carpet fiber density whether a shock pad
was present the mix of rubber and sand
the top layer that stuff stayed
consistent looks like one of the big
measurement differences here was the
shock pad now in this test you know they
show clearly this five ten five
tests that they do across these light
sensors the jump tests that they do it's
really quite fascinating and i often
wonder why we don't do this more for
natural grass it seems like we've got
tons of this stuff for synthetic turf
but they do
get into in this paper john about you
know subjectively participants couldn't
discern the differences in surfaces and
it changes in surface performance uh was
uh different uh
relative to the stiffness or the
softness of the surface so listen here's
some of my questions right i went deep
there for a second and we can go back
into that deep dive but here are the
first ones i want you to go through with
us you know what are some of the minimum
things like you wrote about in that
article that synthetic term people
should be if you've got a synthetic turf
what are the things you should be doing
um i want to talk a little bit about the
difference between infill and single
pile
right obviously some are using infill
some will using field hockey people are
using single pile and then you know just
a general discussion maybe we can have
john about you know how you help
communities make decisions between you
know a synthetic system versus a natural
system so let's start out with the
minimum testing i'm going to look at you
now let's start out with the things
that you recommend anybody that's got
synthetic systems what are you
recommending that they have as a bare
minimum testing regime
definitely a bare minimum is a is an
infill depth gauge
a lot of our research has shown that you
know
when they were doing all that testing
like at university of calgary they
looked at different things with shock
pads and
and what they did was looking at
different systems of infill and maybe in
one of them is the stitch gauge like the
wider and our grandmas might understand
this better when they did their their
their little basket or their little
weaving and gardening or
gardening but they're those little wool
things that they made in their 70s yeah
but you know how wide they are apart and
all that determines how stable the
infill is and how much it moves or
migrates or splashes
and what happens is these aren't
maintenance-free with synthetic turf
and the more what we find is as you've
got a system that's built perfect how
it's supposed to be you start to splash
and migrate infill you now have a build
up somewhere else where maybe there's
more slippage but the other part where
there's what they call more fiber reveal
you got more fibers to grab and wrap
around those cleats and change your
traction
and one of the things we've learned in
talking about this john is a chase and
gerald have done this that athletes can
determine
that inconsistency
sometimes in their footing and that adds
to the
safety concerns so so for you
a local place should it certainly be
testing their infill and trying you know
identifying like gold mouths and sliding
areas
where there's going to be more splashing
and then deal with that do you like
other measurements uh obviously the
thermometer is a good one yeah
thermometer
do they need to do a drop test because
that gets expensive to do gmax doesn't
so gmax is you know it's and and we
don't know what it really tells you and
you know when you look at astm it's an a
missile so you're not going to buy one
of those that's a that's a twenty five
thousand dollar missile not a five
thousand or four thousand dollar like
the plague
um and all those set a maximum it can't
be above this um and when i've the
biggest complaints we've had from
players a lot of times has been that the
fields are too soft so what about
establishing a minimum because you get a
really cushiony surface and all of a
sudden they you think of running on a
beach where you're running you're
running on the firm sand they probably
like it a little bit firmer a little bit
higher
g-max if you look that at that
closer to a maximum not a minimum not
something that's like a 40 or 50 with a
click yeah that's just because you run
on that i mean the standards for i mean
the clegg stuff is also you don't crack
your head open the rotational traction
is the other aspect that you know the
old dell bet the old obj thing yeah uh
you know it was a discoloration stop and
you know that there's a lot that has to
do with the angle that you're you're
planting and of your gait they call it
which can cause it previous injuries
have an effect on it as well so there's
a lot of there's a lot of variables that
go into it but yeah rotational
um and there's rotational devices we
like
the beast has a rotational device um our
we have a rotational device that can
simulate the the forces of an actual
athlete when we try to use the can away
if you remember the the can away
rotational torque
what we find is if we look at high speed
video it doesn't do what an athlete does
is when we look at it and we do it in
slow motion it shows that it actually
kind of lifts it up as you twist it
that's exactly right it doesn't do a
realistic condition so we we we've built
some rotational devices but those aren't
cheap you know to go and test the field
so so you're saying but so that's good i
mean obviously you can spend a lot of
money and you can test a lot of things
but i'm hearing you say and then maybe
that study reveals it that infill depth
if you can only do really one thing and
that would be
you know okay so there's two things
there's what you you need to be doing on
a routine basis and then there's when
the people show up for the warranty
check right don't many synthetic fields
by contracts then for testing and what
is your opinion about that approach yeah
they get they do an annual test um like
a lot of a lot of stadiums will get an
annual test from an independent lab to
come and test things and they'll do the
a-missile
they'll do a planar as well they get
like a two meter long metal bar that's
perfectly straight just to see if
there's any undulations
um and then the others you know
measuring the they could they may have
hick which is a head injury criterium
but again that's a single linear thing
for concussions it's a lot of it's the
rotational stuff that you know
i'm learning from a lot of meetings with
the nfl players association working with
the neurologist that it's rotational
that's causing concussions and there's
no difference between natural and
artificial surfaces for nfl players for
head to surface contact concussions
so there's no difference between natural
grass and synthetic turf for head to
surface contact yeah
and no for nfl players right um
there's no that's not a surprise is it
no no i mean they're getting tackled the
velocity that their heads hitting the
surface you know because of a tackle and
movement or something that's usually
what it is or something that's happening
rotationally
okay so rotationally on the leg on the
head
oh
the concussion on the head
oh the concussions are happening so
these devices like a clegg and these
things that's just a single linear force
so what we now we look at you know the
time like goes back to clay or trey's
phd when he was at penn state with
waddington was looking at the time to
peak with the clay you know what does
that curve look like and what's the area
under the curve at different times
because there's a lot of energy being
returned back and so those are things
that we we look at a lot
with our devices especially our traction
devices it's the time to peak and then
the load going back on the body as well
as how far it displaces in the surface
so that's
what we measure so what but what you're
saying is it's very interesting you
introduce you introduce the idea of a
minimum so soft is good for your head
but not so good for your footing have
you identified some ranges now based on
infill depth what that sweet spot is
yeah um
well it's hard to do on infield depth
because it is there a shock pad is there
what what is the infill is it an organic
infill is it a sand rubber what is the
ratio of the sand rubber what is the
density in the pile height of the fiber
so these things are a myriad
yeah
yeah and this is where the you know we
our research tries to identify you know
the systems that can be the most
consistent because you know people
aren't going to maintain them especially
k through 12 and city park and rec
fields so how do we keep the children
safe you know the nfl does a really good
job of maintaining their synthetic turf
and replacing them every couple the
oldest field is three years old now so
well and then wait wait wait so
but didn't it when there was a whole
hubbub about the giants and the and the
jets last year at meadow and i talked to
mcnitty said it didn't test different
yeah it didn't well it didn't test
different um and you know
injuries are going to happen and they
looked at the way some of those happened
and things like that it was like there's
a lot of high things because the nfl
does
every injury now they do hi they they
look at the video and they look at was
it a contact non-contact how did it hurt
was it the did the foot get locked or
whether they do concussions and all
injuries they monitor so when you when
you look at that system that's
consistent for these k through 12
municipalities uh even you know small
universities that might not have a lot
of resources what are you finding
uh a ton of variability a ton of
variability and i kind of look at it as
if you think you know baseball is the
best sport when you look at after
practice the baseball team goes and fix
the skin they fix the mound they might
mow the grass
well let's do that for artificial turf
let's hey especially lacrosse with a
goalie slamming their foot against that
corner you know look cornell's a big
lacrosse
school you know
have the players like high schools
whatever go out and redistribute that
infill to level it back up one it'll
extend the life of that field but also
keep it uniform and consistent
okay so listen let me let me ask maybe
it's a small question but let's see what
it translates to
do you think if
is there a demonstrable difference in
performance between the single pile and
the infill i mean are people really
moving completely away from single pile
systems or um you know the the just the
carpet with the pistol carpet to a
non-infill system yeah now no i i don't
see
there's one there's one synthetic turf
company that's pushing a non-infill a
lot for um stadiums and they're just
they're coming from europe a swiss
company and they just i know they got
their first six stadium or fields i
think five or six fields in the u.s last
year okay um but you know that the field
hockey is a completely different sport
it they the
the the gold standard for field hockey
is still the old nit nylon original
astro astroturf yeah and that's all
about the ball roll and and and keeping
that field soaking wet yeah
so the ball so you almost see a
rooster tail for the ball
yeah
the field hockey coach drives our
director crazy our director of sports
turf crazy i can imagine yeah it's a but
you know and that's
go back to those old
multiple nub shoes that that's what they
probably should be wearing on those on
that surface so and i don't know what
they wear we don't have field hockey
here but you know i deal with some field
hockey fields we got some in our
research plots and yeah you don't want
to be putting uh
you know the cleats because they're
wearing the same cleats on these infill
systems as they are in grass in the nfl
and they show everywhere everywhere and
you agree with that
um there's the there's there's a list of
shoes that are recommended not to be
worn in the nfl on synthetic turf
because they provide too high of loads
on a translational and a rotational
and you know but the odd time a player
will wear it because they think maybe i
get that extra step on the
on the db covering me and i get that
touchdown and i get the you know but
then also they roll an ankle then
they're they're never the same yeah well
listen
and that's interesting because i you
know you see them make designer streams
and they turn them into ornaments when i
think i've heard both you and andy say
they're safety pieces of safety
equipment those shoes they shouldn't be
viewed as ornaments yeah unfortunately
though the plate the cleat
is still the same it's just that it's
the it's the top that okay good so
they're not messing around with the body
i don't do custom plates because that's
a huge cost for the mold you know it's
easier for them to do the top and make
some sort of thing
but they've you know they've the plates
there's several different plates on the
bottom with cleat designs and cleat
patterns um
and some of them are designed now to do
a better release of rotational but they
change the patterns in it
you know most of the accidents are in a
deceleration or cutting condition not
not a rotational that you see when the
players are getting it lower when
they're when they're when they're
planting and coming in at an angle
that's what you just said trying to stop
and change the direction and then they
they change the gate or the angle of
their their body
or if the pass is slightly behind them
and they slow up and then they catch it
they catch their foot and and if you've
had a
a pre-existing acl injury you're you're
four times more likely two to four times
i believe more likely to
rupture that again
so listen
now it's even higher it's females are
even higher emails are even higher right
there's and some of it we can train
differently right can we should we be
training athletes differently in some
ways especially female athletes yeah
it's there's there's a way of you know
running and jumping and landing but it's
like when you get into the spirit of the
competition and you're going and
something's happening you're focusing on
on
on at that moment it only takes that
instant so it's exactly right you can
train and train and train to get those
kind of like doing a focusing on your
free throw shot constantly constantly
but you know something's gonna happen
when you're when you're over exerted
you're tired
you do yes that's exactly right you know
you often wonder how many injuries occur
later in the game and why you don't want
overtime to run for another hour because
these guys are more likely to get hurt
listen we we got like only a few minutes
and i want to get to i think another
pertinent question you know let me put
you in calgary for let me put you back
home for a minute
if you had a school district that liked
sports in calgary would you advise them
to have a synthetic surface or do you
think northern climates can still have
um
natural grass with early spring and late
falls
they they definitely growing up there we
had great fields like that were great
grass fields and the the the city of
calgary puts a lot of money into their
parks and rec like in in the beauty of
it so it all comes down to you can have
it if you've got the money to invest in
people to maintain it um again synthetic
turf it has its place as well i think uh
you know when it's inclement weather and
it's rainy and stuff it's a place to go
and for children and our data is showing
like when you our traction data shows
for children
when you're below 125 pounds for males
you probably can't generate a big enough
load where it's going to cause lower
extremity injuries once you start
getting that pubescent ages and higher
like 150 175 200 pounds and then you get
above 250 it kind of changes again but
those loads vary um but when you you put
on that force back on your body so it's
it's funny um we had bev palmer who's
probably listening right now yeah he's
on adam
and and uh he says he makes them wear
sneakers in the spring on on the grass
right so they don't dig in and and so
that's actually better right than even
putting the cleat in yeah so
i always thought one of the things i
tell communities is exactly what you
said listen you build it right you
maintain it right
you can't use it 24 7 like you want to
use a synthetic surf system so if you
have an over abundance of activity then
that's where it might work as well and
also when you have a like we do
persistently crappy weather in ithaca
um
you can keep your natural grass fields
nice by putting them on those synthetic
fields in that inclement weather is that
the the sort of process you talk people
through because a lot of times you know
you got one faction that wants to spend
a lot of money because it's high profile
let's have a turf a synthetic turf field
and then you've got this other faction
like we can do grass but it's blah blah
blah how do you help places navigate
that stuff well definitely and it's it's
uh
you got to remember that it's not
maintenance free and a lot of times it's
a one-time capital cost improvement to
so it's easy to go and say we got a
million dollars for a natural or an
artificial field
you know but if you take that same
million dollars and you put it you put
three hundred thousand dollars into a
really good grass field the other seven
700 000 into an endowment can you get
that endowment to pay for that field
first the next in perpetuity yeah i
don't know i mean those are those are
the ways we need to start thinking if
you want to have a grasp but yeah they
can't take the number of games that's
right the artificial turf
does get worn in those heavy areas and
just like gerald and chase's work you
know natural and artificial fields
running from an inconsistent
across an inconsistent surface whether
it's good or bad area it's that change a
lot of times to where those injuries can
occur that they've identified how about
questions carl questions for john
yeah we got a good one from greg and and
it speaks to your point earlier frank
about you know it seems like we're
developing these these specs for
synthetic fields and they're not a
growing plant right so it's easier you
can have those
uh specs but but greg is saying why
can't we do that for natural
uh fields and can we do it by soil type
could we do it by by species
does that seem like the the way we would
do it if we were going to make these
specs and categorize them that way
i think that's that's a great great way
to go i think the work that was done by
alec kololeski for his phd at michigan
state showing how you could change high
school native soil high school fields in
michigan with the sand cap buildup these
fields are performing great year after
year now so it doesn't take a lot and
it's also great to get the
students involved with projects now more
and more schools are wanting education
programs and turf programs why not why
not do that so we don't you know it is
funny john we don't have the same astm
standards for cool see for
natural grass fields that we have for
synthetic
is there discussion of this you're
probably involved in any astm discussion
i would be a little bit admitted with
asdam for a little bit we um
since adam tomes was really here um but
you know they they have some standards
for testing fields but and there's in
the stma now sfma back in the 90s
developed a root zone spec
based off of usga that's the astm root
zone spec and you know they allowed a
greater variance you can have coarser
stand and finer
because you're mowing it at a higher
height but you know we we tested and
compared that and it performs similarly
the same as usga spec so whatever we
don't have i mean you have guidelines
for how hard you are going to let a
field again right you know you guys have
sort of avoided the whole traction thing
with natural grass right yeah there's so
many so much dynamics within it even
across varieties
like we see different varieties of
bermuda grass perform completely
different wow variety
varieties
yeah you know
yeah you would expect the bermuda to
have a little more traction than the rye
grass does it it can but if you've got
one that's more aggressive by stolens
versus rhizomes you know you plant and
it kind of flips up like a comb over in
the wind you know it's just it just pops
up
so you you
or right carl
management are you very grooming because
that makes a whole big difference so you
it's so it's so dynamic it's really hard
i think we could come up with bass lines
of what to do
um and even we're doing a lot of work
with these stabilized solutions we we
tried to uh put out a minimum for for
native soil
you know
for clay and all that because yeah
buddies but yeah and even sand but it
was it was hard to get accepted when
other
reviewers don't
agree with it maybe so that's
interesting other questions carl
just another comment from ben palmer he
said his highest wear areas on field
hockey fields are the corners where
they're slamming their stick in and it
says for him it removes the infill down
to the backing so that's an interesting
uh i think just speaking to the sports
specific you know wear and tear right
yeah i can see that wow that's crazy all
the way down to the bottom of the i
didn't know they liked playing field
hockey on chrome rubber i thought they
liked playing on that single pile
yeah you know they well they they do
like playing usually on but a lot of
schools will just buy one field and it's
going to be a sand rubber infill you've
got to have a good budget to have a
field hockey specific
you see how fast 30 minutes goes we
didn't get any time to say hi john
thanks so much for taking the time
appreciate it carl thank you good to see
you
yes take care you too hey everybody
we'll see you guys we'll see you guys
next week on friday remember thursday's
episode is uh postponed we're going to
be out in the field live out in
rochester for our golf folks on thursday
you can come see us at that gcsa ny
field day uh but for now it's been a
couple of weeks last one yeah we're
almost we're almost done with our third
season i can't believe it so again if
you're listening or on youtube leave a
leave a comment and a rating we really
appreciate the feedback uh until next
week we'll see you guys
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu